hello everyone and welcome to the fifth
and final game of the earthings Masters
final say it is hikarnakamura vs Magnus
Carlson and the first four games ended
in a draw they're playing a rapid time
format and uh okay Magnus was maybe a
little bit better in some of the games
in one game I know I think game two he
was uh completely winning he missed uh a
very tricky idea uh but uh in the end
all he got was four draws and now uh
they go into Armageddon and this time uh
there's a very interesting time control
difference because usually in Armageddon
okay white always has to win the game
otherwise uh black wins the Armageddon
but here uh it is uh uncertain who will
get the black pieces because in
Armageddon it's better to have the black
pieces you can draw and you still win
the match but here you have to bid for
it uh so white will have 15 minutes and
the black gets the bid uh how how little
uh or how much time he wants to have and
interestingly Magnus won the bid by one
second here I have it somewhere let me
just check uh yeah Hikaru Hikaru beat uh
bid 859 so 8 minutes and 59 seconds and
the Magnus bid uh eight minutes and 58
seconds so he outbid Hikaru by one
second which is uh absolutely incredible
like he knew he he knew Hikaru was gonna
probably go below 10 minutes which is
already quite a lot as you start with 15
minutes and he knew that Magnus knew
that so he did he would probably go down
to nine minutes uh and then even below
that but but he figured it out somehow
that Hikaru was gonna go 859 and Magnus
just put in 850 at its uh absolutely
incredible and it's a huge huge Victory
before the first move was even played as
Magnus got the black pieces in
Armageddon and now he uh only needs a
draw to win the match so let's see uh
how Hikaru does it and can he win on
demand against Magnus with the white
pieces for this task he Karu chooses the
reti opening he plays Knight to F3 we
have Knight to F6 by Magnus in the G3
now going for the king's Indian attack
we have a pawn to C5 and the bishop to
G2
all right we have Knight to C6 castles
uh Pawn to D5 grabbing the full Center
and now Pawn to D3 and E5 grabbing even
more Center here we have Pawn to E4 and
now grabbing even more center with Pawn
to D4 we have a four stopping B5 at some
point because now uh the C4 square is
looking very nice for this Knight if
this Knight comes to C4 it's going to be
incredibly strong it's going to put
pressure on the E5 pawn and you will not
be able to dislodge it with a move like
Pawn to B5 so Bishop B7 Knight the A3
going for C4 with Bishop to E6 and now
uh Knight the G5 with Bishop to G4 of
course you do not want to allow Knight
captures Bishop so Bishop to G4 attacks
the Queen Bishop Pawn to F3 Bishop H5
and now Knights the C4 and Hikaru can be
very happy with his uh Knight and C4 not
a lot not a lot has been traded uh or
even nothing has been traded over the
board all the pieces and all the pawns
are still on the board sohikaru can be
very happy with uh with this position
and Knight the C4 is actually a new move
here the position has been reached
before in a very top tier game between
Alexander grishock and Wesley so uh in
Norway chess of 2019 where H4 was played
but here Knight the C4 new move so as of
move 11. uh we have a completely new
game and okay Knight to D7 Magnus offers
some offers some trades the Knight is
attacked here Knight back to each tariki
CaRu wants to avoid any uh trades if
possible with Pawn to F6 and now Knight
to F2 uh Magnus castles and pawn to H4
now Hikaru will now try to push some
pawns the the open up lines of attack
towards the magnus's king Bishop to F7
and now just Bishop to H3 grabbing this
long diagonal and if Magnus ever decides
to trade this bishop for Knight then you
might even be able to put your your
Bishop on E6 so Knight the B6 offers a
trade and now Pawn to B3 Hikaru LED
straight but I'm gonna recapture B
captures on C4 and I like my position
very much so okay Magnus does this
Knight captures B captures
uh and the bishop to D6 with Pawn to F4
uh Hikaru can't just wait and see what
happens he has to open up lines of
attack if he wants to win the match uh
he captures an F4 and now G captures on
F4 now the G file is opened up uh and uh
hikar will try to use it to attack the
the black king So Queen to see seven
putting pressure on the F Pawn and now
Knight the H1 defending with the Rook
end with the bishop there was an
interesting idea uh sort of a towel move
maybe E5 here and then if if captures
then F5 and the position is just a very
very nice for white uh for the moment
you've closed down this diagonal you
freed up the E4 Square for the Knight
the the bishop has access into the game
the queen has access uh you might have
time to double up on the G file so might
not be such a bad idea but okay car went
Knight to H1 uh defends the F4 Pawn
twice now King to h8 by Magnus and now
Knight to G3 with Queen to F3 sorry G6
first with Queen into F3 and now Rook 8
to E8 getting all the pieces into the
action King to H1 preparing to put some
a heavy artillery on the G file and
Bishop to E6 now we have Bishop captures
Rook captures and now Bishop to D2
connecting Rooks uh Ponta F5 and now
Pawn to E5 with Bishop to E7 going after
the H4 pawn and now Hikaru advances it
to H5 and he uh creates some progress
here he now can open up lines of attack
towards the black king G captures an H5
and first Rook to G1 before recapturing
on H5 we have Rook to G6 and now he car
played Queen captures and E6 the correct
capture would be Knight captures and H6
uh sorry on H5 but after Queen captures
an H5 he allows Magnus a very very
tricky idea which Magnus missed during
the game but you however will not as you
guys are awesome so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for Magnus uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
wild idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is night
captures an E5 point being uh that you
want to open up this diagonal and the
problem is now if you don't if you don't
capture the Knight is coming to G4 and
then it's just gonna be a monster there
uh and if you capture it's not much
better just Queen the C6 check and you
don't have a good reply if Rook Rogue
blocks then you can just capture the
Knight that The Rook will be overwhelmed
and if King to H2 now you play F4
absolutely stunning move uh attacking
the Knight here also preventing the
Bishop from helping out with the H6
Square so Rook to H6 will just win the
White Queen uh there there's absolutely
nothing you can do here whatever you do
you just get destroyed but instead after
Queen to H5 Magnus played Knights the B4
uh as this is Armageddon he only needs a
drawing he doesn't want to spare spend
any extra seconds on her trying to find
the win because if you get a low on time
there is no increment in Armageddon
hikar will just Crush you so Queen to F3
goes back we have Knight characters and
C2 and Rook 8 to B1 Knight back to B4
and Rook to G2 Hikaru has to look for
ways to attack the black king or to
somehow create some winning chances he
does have pressure against that B7 pawn
and he does have the past D Pawn uh past
D Pawn so it could go well for him Queen
to C6 Magnus quickly offers a queen
trade and Hikaru obliges Queen captures
with B captures on C6 and now Knight to
E2
remanuvering the Knight here Knight
captures on D3 and now Rook the V7
putting pressure on the bishop on the
pawn and on the seventh rank in general
if the Rook can come to H2 maybe you you
will have some success here so Rook to
E8 and defends the bishop now comes
Knight to C1 uh offers a trade of Knight
we have characters captures and now Pawn
to A6 we have rooked the B6 goes after
the A6 pawn pawn to A5 now and now
Bishop to D2 again puts pressure on the
A5 Pawn uh Pawn to D3 uh and now Rook
captures on G6 first with h characters
King to G2 both players start bringing
the king into the game King to G7 and
now Rook captures and C6 here uh Rook to
V7 was the way to go uh or maybe just
improve the activity of your king but
after Rook captures and C6 uh Magnus
just gains too much time we have Rook to
d8 King to F3 and now Rook to D4 now if
it's pressure on the C4 Pawn Rook the E6
attacks the bishop sorry Rook to E6
would have been one way to go about it
but Hikaru plays Rook to A6 and now puts
more pressure on the A5 Pawn uh Rook
captures on c for Rook captures on A5
and now Rook the C2 attacks the bishop
Bishop to E3 and now Pawn to C4 again
Magnus not looking for a win Rook to H2
is just um
is just crushing here there's uh not all
that much to do and the capturing on C5
is never really an option because then
just spawn to D2 so Rook H2 was the way
to go uh Magnus starts advancing Pawn to
C4 we have Rook the A7 attacks the
bishop King to f8 and now Pawn to A5
again uh Hikaru misses the very nasty E6
E6 is just uh beautiful uh covers the
the F7 square if the bishop comes here
you cover this Square then some checking
ideas uh it's nothing forced but it will
be enough tactics to hold at least a
draw but the draw isn't anything good
for Hikaru so uh it's a it's a great
move but it doesn't help his match
situation because he has to win the
Armageddon game so Ponte A5 the way to
usually do this is to just continue
pushing your outside pass pawn and now
Rook the A2 here again Rook to H2 is the
way to win Magnus goes Rook to A2 and
now we have uh Ponte A6 we have Pawn to
C3 now the two connected spawns are
deadly Rook the D7 and Magnus can uh
continue pushing with D2 which is
winning but he goes for Rook captures on
A6 he wants the uh he he doesn't want
the win he wants not to lose as he needs
to win or win the match that way so Rook
captures on D3 and like I said both
players are down to like a minute and a
half and if you get below the one minute
Mark then you're just the bulleting
against Hikaru that's never really
Pleasant uh so Rook to C6 and now Bishop
the C1 of course you don't want to worry
about that past Pawn King to F7 now
comes Rook The Rook to D7 uh we have
Pawn to C2 and now Rook to B7 going for
that
um
uh upon at some point but also you want
to keep an eye on the bishop and the
King here so King the E6 now comes King
to E2 we have Pawn to G5 uh creating
another pass Pawn F captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop captress and G5
uh doesn't really do all that much on
the C1 Queen uh and now Rook the E7
check before uh before recapturing uh
luckily uh for Magnus it's not a
Checkmate uh if the D5 Square was
somehow guarded it would be Checkmate
but he does have the D5 square and now
he has to capture Queen Bishop captures
on C1 Rook captures and now King to F3
uh and here Rook to C4 and he was in
this position on move 60 that Hikaru and
Magnus agreed to a draw uh as there is
nothing more to be done here uh so uh
four games ended in a draw and then the
Armageddon game ended in a draw which
means that Magnus wins the match and
basically it all came down to as they it
doesn't uh look like they are able to
defeat each other and these shorter time
controls because out of the four games
before Armageddon Magnus was like I said
he was winning one of the games and one
he was probably winning one he was
better he was never really worse but he
couldn't uh win a single game against
Hikaru and now yeah even though he was
winning throughout the entire game again
he he settled for a draw for those of
you who are interested why this is a
draw uh it's because even though black
can for example win this Pawn uh you
will not be able to to promote your your
F Pawn the way to show this uh the
simplest as possible let's say you give
a check here now after the king moves
you will gobble up upon white can even
trade you don't have to keep the Rooks
on the board white gains the opposition
and you can never promote your Pawn
because you want to kick away the white
king and put your king in front of the
past Pawn but you cannot do this so you
have to push the pawn and now you will
just continue doing the
uh opposition and after let's say after
we checking to F1 King E3 you will do
king E1 again F to check King ft one and
now after black is forced to get
opposition because if you play anything
else then white will just uh win the
pawn so you have to play this and now
it's a draw by by stalemate uh White
King has no squares so it's a draw uh of
course both of them know this and after
Rook to C4 they agree to a draw and
Magnus wins a very very nice match uh he
wasn't a very happy or very uh proud of
this he said I believe uh later on in an
interview that it was a a very poor
showing in in all the games uh in that
he is sure that Hikaru would agree I
haven't seen if Hikaru agreed to it but
uh yeah I imagine neither of them are
very happy even though Magnus won the
match uh it's uh five drawn games and I
guess I I don't think he he's very very
proud of that but yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed the story about
being away from YouTube
um for like a week my voice was not
working at all again my daughter brought
something from a kindergarten as she she
does
quite often and this one was it was a
deadly one so yeah it took me it took me
a while to recover but hopefully now I
will
um you know uh be well for for uh for
the foreseeable future uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any other cool games that I've
missed because I haven't really been
following what's been going on in the
Chess World uh do use hashtag suggestion
I will go over them and I will cover
them you know especially the cool ones
uh so yeah once again really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube uh Adam
Hamill uh
Jeffrey Lockwood and Kerry Smith for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and yeah as
as Mikhail tal the great once said
rumors of my death were greatly
exaggerated see you soon